- We must find a way to
look after one another
as if we were one single tribe.
- The passing of Chadwick
Boseman has left fans devastated,
not only because of the
impact of his films,
but because of the lives
he touched as a person.
So today we're gonna talk about Chadwick
and his lasting legacy
right now on "The Ketchup."
Since it was announced
that Chadwick Boseman died
from colon cancer at the age of 43,
the outpouring of love
and sadness has come
from all over the world,
especially from his
peers and collaborators,
like longtime friend Michael B. Jordan,
who wrote on Instagram,
"I'm more aware now than
ever that time is short
with people we love and admire.
I'm gonna miss your
honesty, your generosity,
your sense of humor,
and incredible gifts."
And "Black Panther"
writer-director Ryan Coogler said
in a tribute that, much
like the rest of us,
he didn't know the details
of Chadwick's illness.
He wrote, "Because he was
a caretaker, a leader,
and a man of faith, dignity, and pride,
he shielded his collaborators
from his suffering.
He lived a beautiful life.
And he made great art.
Day after day, year after year.
That was who he was."
And "Shang Chi and the Legend
of the 10 Rings" star Simu Liu
gave a cool nod when he wrote,
"I wanna be crystal clear:
without Chadwick and what
he gave to his character,
there is no Shang Chi, period.
My career rides on the
coattails of a great man."
- [Soldiers] Yibambe!
- Yibambe!
- [Naz] And of course it wasn't
just friends and colleagues
who felt this loss.
Countless fans have
shared a similar sentiment
to this Twitter user who said,
"The way 'Black Panther'
showed so many Black children
that they could be the superhero,
his work really meant the world to us.
Thank you."
And to sum that up in video
form is this reposting
from the Ron Clark Academy
when a whole school found out
that they were going
to see "Black Panther."
Chadwick himself
understood and talked about
what the film meant to
the Black community,
like in this interview
at SiriusXM in 2018.
He broke down while talking about two kids
with terminal cancer that
he was communicating with
during filming who both eventually passed
and how excited they
were for "Black Panther."
- Yeah, it means a lot.
- [Naz] But it wasn't just
his role as to T'Challa
where Chadwick made a difference.
He played a number of
historical Black figures
in his short career,
receiving high praise from
critics and fans each time.
And one fan on Twitter pointed out that
"His work accelerated the representation
for African Americans
while also paving the way
for other POCs, such as Hispanics
and Asians in Hollywood."
The first of those roles
was as Jackie Robinson
in 2013's Certified Fresh "42."
The film put Chadwick's name
and a well-told piece of
history on people's radars.
Interestingly and sadly,
Chadwick passed on this
year's Jackie Robinson Day
in Major League Baseball that
normally falls on April 15th,
but was rescheduled due to COVID.
And it was 73 years to the
day that Jackie Robinson
became the first Black man
whites let play baseball.
- You will remember me.
- [Naz] Chadwick also played
the Godfather of Soul,
James Brown, in 2014's "Get On Up,"
a film that is Certified Fresh at 80%,
mostly thanks to a
performance from Chadwick
that had critics using
adjectives like "unforgettable,"
"dynamite," and "startling,"
just to name a few.
- When I hit that stage,
your people better be ready,
especially the white folk.
- [Naz] And in 2017's "Marshall,"
Chadwick portrayed Supreme
Court Justice Thurgood Marshall
in the early days of
his career as a lawyer,
once again impressing critics,
like Rolling Stone's
Peter Travers, who said,
"Charged by Boseman's dramatic lightning,
'Marshall' gives us an
electrifying glimpse
of a great man in the making."
- The only way to get
through a bigot's door
was to break it down.
- [Naz] But beyond his acting prowess
and the important roles that he chose,
Chadwick was, by all
accounts, a very genuine
and sincere person, both on set
and when he was out in public.
Actress Brie Larson echoed
that sentiment on Twitter
by saying, "He took the time to really see
how you were doing and
gave words of encouragement
when you felt unsure."
And many on social media
made comments like this one
from Sal on Facebook, who said,
"He was not only an amazing actor
but an amazing human being.
Hollywood lost a great one too soon."
One strong example of his
wisdom and ability to speak
to others can be found in
this commencement speech
Chadwick gave at his alma mater,
Howard University, in 2018.
It is a must-watch and
includes words like this:
- Purpose is an essential element of you.
It is the reason you are on the planet
at this particular time in history.
Your very existence is
wrapped up in the things
you are here to fulfill.
Whatever you choose for a career path,
remember the struggles
along the way are only meant
to shape you for your purpose.
(sweeping instrumental music)